brought to you by PlayStation Store
access to the ultimate and games and
entertainment I'll just followed by the
phantom pain that's coming at this year
we didn't know whether it was going to
come out and then some I don't know some
some Italian ass video on IGN packed up
at this morning for a little bit
somebody on got spotted it as they
always tend to do and now we know
apparently September first is when
Microsoft five gracias chris is not eggs
you know like Micah so nice so so
overrated I don't know people get so
excited about them something than to
honor them yeah well better than Armand
super yeah you view not a mega cell
phone either I haven't played it like I
wanted a PlayStation when I was a kid
and my parents told me to shut up and go
outside play so I thought we aren't
gonna like being done you should just
have a child right there like Chris go
outside and play with the goats yeah
Mike I'm gonna take a guess based on
what volume looks like that perhaps
you're a fan of melodious olives I've
never played though there are many times
there is a slight visual similarity who
pointed out to me every kind of ten
minutes on Twitter it's fun oh yeah no
it's a I'd only real life and in real
life you taken a ticket um yeah no it's
cool I'm excited obviously I'm big male
gay fan I I and there was the first to
september's sorry yeah I can exclusively
confirm that volume will not be out sep
2015 idol Italy that's a month or will
be avoided like is that something you
think like because you know with the
sort of the scale and the different
markets that people are buying games now
is that still something that you try and
stay away from anyways like there's lots
of schools of thought so like we so
Thomas was alone for example came out
the same day as call of duty right so
there's this thing emitter with TV
scheduling like they graduate program at
counter program exactly so if there's a
big sports game on your pointer romantic
comedy because you figure the audiences
are different you're giving something
for foreach audience but the but yeah so
with with like another any other at run
choice I would probably be like yeah
they're cool they're different audience
too but now I'm trying to launch a
stealth franchise oh there are a
different day 22 to domestic mr. hideo
kojima's there you go well yeah or hand
and how many weeks you give for buddy to
give the month clearance afterwards
client must be this massive
rolling open war the answer to your game
is I checked the bug list when they get
home about but yeah so it's it's it's
cool I me I'm super excited I Mel gear
yeah it'll be a it'll be all take a
weekend off and you work my way through
why don't know how big it is it looks
massive yeah might be one of the weaker
did you play much ground zeroes at all
cuz i dont Danny you were super ended I
i really like rancheros like I think the
road I like those games to replay levels
so like it was completely perfectly down
my alley like I still of thing games
like project IGI and like doing the same
level over and over I know right budget
I'm doing in like rainbow six like i'd
say like rogue spear level and that's
how it feels and that's what's
interesting about it is it has gone into
this kind of more kind of generalist
like smart like it's it's a it's not
just stealth anymore it's this kind of
like SAS simulator kind of thing you're
kind of you're using the weaponry and
you're using the environment activates
it's cool it's fun i did for a rival
outlet i did a really interesting
interview where it was me and one of the
designers from that guy from from well
from both of the new metal gear and just
just hearing how he talked about it and
what their goals were was just
fascinating right but the the scale of
interaction possibilities and tilly felt
like ground zeroes you could see it in
there that was that was you could tackle
that a host of different ways i let me
get to other thing was an accident that
was so short that people had to replay
because I think through the replay you
realize oh actually I could have done
yeah all these little things so I'm
excited to see that in a big game
content especially with all the extra
cardboard boxes with ladies painted on
that they're bringing in the venom and I
mean it's just what was really lacking i
said i do remember yeah I remember
because I was on stage at Gamescom /
Sony and we wish I watched the the box
trailer know about 20 times every day
because obviously you're you're looping
play in the rehearsals and stuff I was
just glad I didn't do like a whole
presentation where all they did was play
those [ __ ] up tapes from grand zeros
over and over and over again yeah yeah I
don't know some of them watch none of
that series there are some little things
some about guys yeah that creepy yeah
yeah but there you go September first is
when volume will not be coming out of
here on gamespot com
you